it's now been about one month since
Apple's new M2 Pro and M2 Max MacBook
Pros were announced and as you probably
already know we went absolutely Ham on
the comparisons with 14 videos
jam-packed with a bunch of tests and
while we still have more to go this
review will basically wrap all of our
findings so far into one easy to digest
review including what actually got a lot
faster what didn't gaming performance
thermal throttling SSD issues Wi-Fi
changes and much more as well as my
recommendation for whether you should
buy one of these or not so let's get
right into it of course we know that the
design and Main feature set hasn't
changed at all with the exception of
HDMI 2.1 which will really only matter
for a small number of people this update
is all about the internal specs and
changes so if you care more about the
design changes and user-facing features
like a better display or anything like
that then you've got to wait until the
next update likely sometime in 2024. now
as far as the internal changes we simply
have upgraded M2 family chips that use
more power and we have new wireless
specs the downside is that there are
really no physical changes or upgrades
in terms of the cooling system to
compensate for the more power hungry
chips in fact the heat sinks are now
smaller this time around which likely
leads to slightly worse cooling
performance Apple did this because they
rearranged their memory layout to use
less physical space on the soc package
as you can see in this image from iFixit
and they did that because there was an
interposer supply chain shortage which
is the green material you see underneath
the chips which houses all of the fine
intricate wiring between the chips and
Main logic board and since the heatsink
only needs to cover the actual chips
there's no reason have a larger one
hence the smaller heat sink this year
and if you're wondering about how this
impacts performance alongside the more
power hungry chips I've got some good
news and I've got some bad news but
first I've got to mention the changes to
the wireless specs as for Wi-Fi 6E Max
tested this extensively in a video
dedicated to this topic which you can
check out if you care enough but the
main point was that the new six
gigahertz band was quite unreliable
unless the router is nearby or in the
same room but thankfully Apple actually
upgraded the regular 5 gigahertz
antennas on these new Macbook Pros so
the Wi-Fi performance gets a big upgrade
even without Wi-Fi 6E which is great to
hear now as far as the battery life
these models are actually quite a bit
better especially when doing very light
tasks like web browsing now nothing
about the actual batteries have changed
they're still the same size as before
the better battery life comes from the
two additional efficiency cores in the
new M2 Pro and Max chips which are now
also faster than they were before this
means that the power hungry performance
cores don't need to be activated as
often when doing light tasks leading to
power savings however if you're
constantly putting a heavy load on these
machines the battery life will actually
be worse like dave2d tested and showed
off of course because these chips are
more power hungry due to the faster 3.5
gigahertz clock speed and the extra
cores now before I get into something
that Apple has never done before with
their silicon I've got to tell you guys
about our partner moth's brand new
foldable five in one sit and stand
laptop desk the moft Z not only is it
super thin so it can easily fit into
your bag or on your shelf but it's the
only stand that offers both a Sit and
Stand posture in a one-piece design
being super quick and easy to set up
being perfect for the new Macbook Pros
so you can stand up and use it
comfortably and then we can easily drop
it down and set it up with different
angles including 25 35 45 or even a 60
degree angle for iPads and to completely
experience moft also has their snap
phone mount which allows you to mount
your iPhone right on the back of your
MacBook and use it as a webcam with the
new continuity camera feature or even
Mount your iPhone on the side of your
display for a multitasking setup so go
ahead and check out both the mobbed Z
and the moff snap phone mount using the
links in the description below now the
one brand new unique change this year is
that the M2 Max 16 inch bottle can clock
even higher while in high power mode
specifically up to 3.68 gigahertz which
led to a single core score of over 2050
points and the geekbench 5 Benchmark
about five percent higher than the other
models clocked at 3.5 gigahertz now
usually this would mean that all of your
single core tasks are significantly
faster like web browsing as shown with
the speedometer web browsing Benchmark
but nope for some reason we didn't
really see much gains at all across
multiple tests like our figma web design
test project provided to us by our
partners 500 designs based out of Los
Angeles smoothness while zooming into
the web pages was basically the same as
well as the actual final export time not
really being much different so I'd say
that 3.68 gigahertz clock speed doesn't
really matter that much now what does
matter is thermal throttling
specifically with the 14 inch model but
before I get into that I've got to
mention the ssds yes the base 512 gig
models of these laptops still have the
same SSD Nan chip issue as we had with
the M2 MacBook Air where Apple has cut
down the number of nand chips or
basically raw storage chips by half
compared to the previous base models and
compared to the new one terabyte SSD
models this leads to slower SSD transfer
speeds as well as slower SSD swap
performance which is essentially the
process of the system borrowing SSD
storage to use as RAM memory in the
event that the ram starts getting full
two times less SSD Nan chips means two
times less Lanes or bridges for that
data to travel back and forth which
creates a traffic jam that slows down
this system compared to the previous 512
gig SSD model which had two times more
chips or Lanes which could handle this
SSD swap process better and faster and
to simulate this we opened 15 Chrome
tabs while also testing real world
applications like exporting Raw photos
in Lightroom classic and we found that
even though the new M2 pro model is
significantly faster when nothing else
is open in the background it actually
becomes slower than the previous model
due to this SSD swap issue when you have
tabs open but don't worry it's nowhere
near as bad as it was on the M2 MacBook
Air because one these Pro Models come
with 16 gigs of Base memory so it's
harder to hit the limit and to the
actual SSD chips themselves are much
faster on these ones than they are on
the air so because of that most tasks
that we tested like programming and
video editing didn't really see much of
an impact it was mostly just photo
editing because it's extremely reliant
on RAM that's actually really good news
and we can safely give the okay to buy
these 512 gig SSD base models for those
who are really trying to save money but
only if the tasks that you're working
with don't rely heavily on the ram photo
editors should absolutely get at least
one terabyte of SSD in order to get the
full amount of SSD nand chips to solve
this issue and now let's finish off with
the general performance yes the new
models are around 15 to 23 faster in
terms of the CPU performance for things
like programming photo editing CPU
rendering or whatever else and yes the
single core performance has improved by
about 16 percent leading to a snappier
machine overall for common apps and web
browsing so that's definitely a nice
boost but as for the graphics we
compared similarly spec chip models
going from the M1 Pro and M1 Max chip to
the new M2 versions and in the gaming
benchmarks we saw about 22 to 29 more
performance and I actually did a full
game review video where I tested a bunch
of games on the new 38 core M2 Max model
and the results were honestly not that
great and a lot of the non-optimized Mac
games like League of Legends and
Starcraft 2 which are relying on Rosetta
2 translation I only saw about 10 to 15
gains in fps the windows game GTA 5
surprised me by being over 60 faster but
that may have been due to some
optimizations that crossover made over
the past year and a half but what really
shocked me was the performance of World
of Warcraft which is fully optimized for
metal and it saw huge gains so for
anyone playing that game or other metal
optimized games like the new Resident
Evil Village it's definitely worth
getting the new 38 core M2 Max but for
other things like video editing I
honestly wasn't that impressed with very
minimal gains for tasks that rely on the
media engines which means the h.264 a
265 and prores codex if you're like most
people and you're editing using those
codecs do not bother upgrading and even
for unsupported codecs it wasn't a huge
difference anyway like being just 15
faster for the 8K red raw export test
but where it really shined was blender
3D rendering where most tasks were 42 to
45 faster and some even got close to
twice as fast and those were the best
games we saw across the board so 3D
renderers rejoice and to finish off with
this review the last thing I've got to
mention is the 14 inch M2 Max model with
the 38 core GPU for some reason apple is
choosing to clock the GPU on the 14-inch
M2 Max model down even when it's not
hitting its thermal limits for example
the 16 inch model was 20 faster in a
quick gaming benchmark test and when
pushing them to their limits with both a
CPU and GPU stress test at the same time
the 16 inch model finished with a 2.5
times higher CPU score and a nine
percent higher GPU score the reason for
that was because the fans on the 14-inch
literally can't handle the heat of both
the CPU and GPU running under load at
the same time which leads to a chassis
temperature of around 52 degrees Celsius
which forces Apple to slow down the chip
performance drastically so if you care a
ton about sustained performance under
load and maximizing the performance of
your machine do not buy the 14 inch M2
Max model with the 38 core GPU so now
with all those results out of the way my
recommendation is to honestly just wait
another year and a half until the M3 Pro
and Max MacBook Pro Models are here or
better yet if you don't need a ton of
performance just wait for the new M3
MacBook air coming likely in the fall
which will have brand new CPU and GPU
cores on tsmc's three nanometer process
and if you absolutely must buy something
right now then go ahead there's still
great machines but I wouldn't recommend
going all out on the upgrades like the
ssds since you might be tempted to buy
one of the new M3 models when they
eventually come out so hopefully you
enjoyed watching this review and if you
did go ahead and click the circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
one check out one of those two right
over there including the Wi-Fi 6E test
video thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
[Music]
foreign